[Laughter]
said
black seed oil will cure anything except
death
uh so um maybe we can give some to this
brother who's in the video
but do check out nature's blending
challenges
brothers and sisters and dear friends uh
welcome to another reaction video this
this one's gonna be quite interesting
uh it's gonna be quite entertaining but
a lot of lessons to be learned
uh before i start i wanna praise allah
the most merciful the most trust or
praise his glory and gratitude belong to
him
for the works that we're doing at salaam
studios and we want to thank every
single one of you guys for believing in
us and helping us
to carry on these works um this specific
video is sponsored by nature's blend
as you can see the products in front of
me much like they do a black seed oil
olive oil honey different kind of honey
even if you open
uh black seed extra black seeds in that
little bag
so do check them out the link be in the
description box below
this guy
[Laughter]
yeah he's always like this okay so
i came across this video yeah and i
thought i'll share it with you guys um
it's quite interesting
and i think there's a lot of lessons to
be learned uh inshallah if you haven't
if you do have any christian friends
do share this with them so here we go
are you ready
okay so this video is of a dead man
coming alive okay
and this is a landlord and are you who
are you family members
the mother of the wife come here this is
a wife
i want you guys to look carefully at his
mouth here that this is chocolate
decision
come here this is a wife
okay okay okay okay
this is
jesus
[Music]
jesus what is his name jesus
i remember seeing this stuff from
ghanaian tv you know we went to ghana
really
yeah i was looking through the channels
i saw this guy i think it was him
he might be yeah
it's commanding your life
[Music]
[Music]
okay
you know this is yeah literally uh
the definition of ship essentially yeah
yeah there's people that actually
believe this stuff but um
now obviously it's a scam yeah
because you can see when he's there you
can see his tongue moving he's breathing
yeah okay
and then they've hired some actors which
is the landlord of him
and his mom etc um but an interesting
verse that
uh came to my mind was surah maid i
think it's verse 17 117
says that if if if allah says if i was
to
destroy uh isa um
and his mother yes and who would come to
help him you know
so you know 117. is it 117. because
there's only one 20 verses 120 verses of
the
surah oh i listen to the answer no yeah
yeah yeah it's 117. so
you know it is anything that you can
share for people that actually believe
this because we need to bear in mind
that
it's not just christians that believe
this kind of stuff it's also from
muslims
and different uh people from i mean
faith is wrong yeah
giving life to the death yeah to the
dead
is from the attributes
the one who gives life than the one who
gives death and this characteristic is
from
the attributes of allah and no one has
this to sarah
no one has this country this ability to
control the existence
other than allah okay
but christians who are watching this
will be like you know what we've got the
muslims
because jesus did this in the bible so
so if you see that yet yes it be oh be
it
be
in that particular instance and he made
it very clear just like
the jed for example will give life to
the death exactly
with the permission of who with the
pressure of allah as a fitna as a
triangular tribulation to the people
so what would you say like if there's
some christians watching this or people
say yeah about
do you know a lot of prophets had
miracles but it was never
the same as jesus you know giving the
life to the dead
and that's this mentioned in the bible
like if this if someone's watching this
how would you
yeah well i mean what first and foremost
we have
if we accept that all of the other
prophets did miracles
like moses and in the bible in the quran
and all those
different texts that actually means that
there's a common thread that runs
through
which is that they all have been given
the ability to do miracles
and so why would we differentiate
between the miracles of moses and
miracles of jesus i mean
if we see that the miracles of moses
couldn't have been done through him
so we should we should in the same light
say okay well the miracles of jesus
had he was used as an agency but he
wasn't the
the reason for the miracles so i guess
if we if we cite the existence of
miracles and earlier prophets
as a as an evidence all it will be in
evidence to is the fact that this is not
a special thing that only jesus was
given
if jesus was the only person in the in
in the scriptures that had been given
these miracles then
there'd be a different different kind of
discussion but
so do we have islam do we have like okay
this miracle is greater than this one
do we have this consequence in a sense
the quran is there we say that
you know the greatest miracle of all the
thing is in terms of
in terms of you know in terms of
um proximity this is a very interesting
question because you know um who
who actually witnesses the miracle you
know and within the case of all of the
other prophets and messengers
it was the primary audience the people
in their vicinity and people that saw it
but the thing is the quran is meant to
be a preserved miracle for anyone at any
time to be able to examine
that miracle so in other in other words
had the miracles of the quran
only been things like you know prophets
raising the dead or
during the blind we would have a
disadvantage in that because we wouldn't
be able to see
existing the eternal miracle is called
yeah yeah it's
describes it as being one of the
greatest the greatest of the signs
um i think also one issue to touch upon
is
what does believe essentially when it
comes to
miracles and it's a long issue but just
to summarize it we believe that
in arabic we differentiate between the
term jesus which is known as translated
to to the word english miracle yeah but
also between the word karama as well
which is also translated as a miracle as
well we believe that the that the
miracles are given to the prophets
and the karma that are given to that
only of allah who are the only the close
pious people of allah who are these
people
that these
[Music]
people as a way of keeping the invested
fast for a a benefit either a
a d benefit a muscle hadinia or it could
be something
as well but it's not and this is very
important they don't
have these miracles at their own behest
right they don't say okay i'm going to
show you a miracle now
and walk over the fire and or whatever
so this is
in fact a signed partisan actually talks
about this
one of his beautiful books criterion
between the awliya of allah and the holy
ashraman
he says that this is actually defining
characteristic you find that firstly
if a person is not turkey if he doesn't
fear allah
then he does not have qaram from allah
these are these are from the works of
the shayatin themselves
but if he is someone who is fearful of
allah and he doesn't call upon these
miracles
from his own behest yeah but rather
there is a muscle had it has a
purpose and a benefit and it happens at
that particular time out of his control
then we accept that as a karamah
possibly
yeah it's true you're not coming to just
just wrapping up um the the things that
you said because i was speaking to a
christian once and i said to him just
keep saying jesus is miracles he brought
life to the dead etc
i said to be honest [ __ ] him just an
agnostic and i said you prove it you can
never prove that to me ever
you can never ever prove to me that
jesus did that but as an if an agnostic
came to me i can use the quran which is
tangible he can
read it yeah for himself and see it so
if you're going to come with that
argument
i'll come and say the quran is a greater
miracle than that yeah because they can
verify it for themselves do you get them
yeah and you know the reason why
emotions that came
what's the purpose why were the prophets
given oh yeah yeah the prophets were
given miracles
to prove their authenticity and their
truthfulness yes and also to cater for
that specific audience at that time
because moses was given a different
miracle
so it only makes sense if for example
the old testament or the new testament
was meant
to be a the last messenger one of the
last mysteries for people of all times
and places the final testament
the final testament so therefore it
makes certain did they say that the
fantastic
i say that the other the old testament
the new testament is the final testament
yeah finish the book off
so it makes sense for for for there to
be some way if i say assassinating the
truth of this
yeah are you through miracles yeah
because that is one of the the
self of the quran exactly and for those
who have any basic logic and
and a mind to think with i think it's
very clear you know
instead of worshiping the creation to
worship the creator and in the book of
acts chapter 2 verse 22 it clearly says
jesus of nazareth a man
chosen by god with wonders miracles and
signs which
god did through him um and it's very
simple brother sisters i hope you guys
have benefited from this inshallah
um and it's very simple you know to
worship allah alone
it's it's it's when i first came to
islam i used to think to myself
like i just have to see the shahada and
enter like that's it
that's the easiest thing ever but
learning things
people just cannot for some reason
they're attracted to [ __ ]
it's weird it's really like what why is
it so hard for you to worship god alone
oh i'm a sinner and it's so and then you
realize when alaska says
dying in shahadah then when i understood
the penalty dropped for me of this
matter is not as black as white as you
think it's hard
but inshallah brother sisters you guys
benefited from this and this man i'm
very sure he wasn't dead i don't know if
he's still alive today
uh but talking on that and finishing the
video um
nature's blend the prophet sallam said
black seed oil will cure anything except
death
uh so um maybe we can give some to this
brother who was in the video
but uh do you check out nature's
blending challenges
we got black seed oil you know you never
know
uh but insha'allah do check their
website and shall i want to thank them
for sponsoring this video may allah
bless them inshallah
amazing products actually and the books
that came in as well was very nice
um inshallah until next time from me uh
prophet muhammad
may allah bless you inshallah uh keep
awakening sha allah
nature's blend if you have anything for
this guy to keep awake inshaallah please
do send it get into espresso or
something like that